lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
pensar acerca de la multiplicación o en
estrategias para multiplicar números que
están expresados en términos de decenas
centenas o millares y lo vamos a ver en
este ejemplo tenemos 800 x 400 ahora
como siempre los animo a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo vamos a
resolverlos juntos y lo voy a resolver
de la manera en que mi cerebro le gusta
abordarlo cuando tengan práctica serán
capaces de hacer este tipo de problemas
de multiplicación incluso sin tener que
escribirlo así que la clave aquí es
decir oye estos son 800 que es lo mismo
que 8% y estos son 400 que es lo mismo
que 4% entonces tenemos 8% por 4% y si
estamos multiplicando tantos números
como estos podemos cambiar el orden en
el que estamos haciendo la
multiplicación así que lo podemos ver
como 8 por 4
por 100% porque es más fácil hacerlo así
bueno cuanto es 8 por 4 si sabemos las
tablas de multiplicar 8 por 4 es igual a
32 32 por cuánto es 100% hay muchas
formas de pensar en esto y quiero que
realmente piensen en esto pero pronto
veremos que hay una manera bastante
rápida de asegurarnos que lo hicimos
bien pero una manera de pensar en esto
déjenme hacerlo aquí y es por cien es
igual a mil cien por cien es igual a
10.000 así que esto que tenemos aquí es
igual a 10.000 ahora tal vez no tenga
algo interesante aquí tengo dos ceros y
otros dos ceros en total son cuatro
ceros y tengo cuatro ceros aquí cada vez
que multiplican por 10 tienen que
agregar un cero si multiplican por 100
tienen que agregar dos ceros si
multiplican por mil tienen que agregar
tres ceros y pueden ver esto aquí
entonces tenemos 32 por 10.000 cuál es
el resultado
vamos a ver 32 por mil serían 32.000
pero esto es 32 por 10.000 esto es igual
a 320 mil ahora probablemente no tiene
un patrón interesante aquí 32 por uno
seguido de cuatro ceros es igual a 32
seguido de cuatro ceros
esto es 32 por 10.000 lo que es 320 mil
ahora otra forma de pensar en esto es 8
por 4 nos da 32 y luego tenemos dos
ceros aquí y otros dos ceros aquí son un
total de cuatro ceros que son los cuatro
ceros que tenemos acá ahora no quiero
que simplemente memorice en esto esto
funciona porque estos son 800 x 400 8 x
4 es igual a 32 y luego 100% de aquí es
de dónde vienen los 4 ceros
hagamos otro ejemplo hagamos 30 por 700
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
podemos hacerlo como lo hicimos
anteriormente 30 es igual a 3 por pies
por y 700 es igual a 7 por 100
así que si decimos 3 por 7 es igual a 21
por 10 por 100 que es igual a 1000
entonces cuánto es 21 por 1000 esto es
igual a 21.000 así que como lo vimos
antes una vez que tengan práctica quiero
que siempre entiendan de dónde viene
todo esto
3 por 7 es igual a 21 y luego van a
multiplicar 10 por 100 que es igual a
1000 así que tenemos 12 30 12 30 vamos a
hacer un ejemplo más digamos que
queremos multiplicar 2000 por 8000 pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo tal
vez en su mente traten de hacer este en
su mente bueno
no se sientan mal si tienen que escribir
lo bueno tal vez ya lo pueden hacer
ahora tal vez puedan decir oye 2 x 8 es
igual a 16 y luego tengo 3 ceros más 3
ceros que va a ser igual a 6 ceros 1 2 3
4 5 6 ceros
lo que me da 16 millones y esto es
absolutamente correcto ahora quiero que
refuercen lo que están haciendo cuando
cuentan ceros como lo hicieron aquí
cuando lo hacen es como decir oye esto
es lo mismo que 2 por mil
por ocho por mil y luego solo cambiamos
el orden de la multiplicación y
multiplicamos primero el 2 por el 8 lo
que nos da 16 y luego multiplicamos por
1000 y por mil y mil por mil es igual a
un millón y aquí tenemos un millón y
fíjense que lo podemos ver aquí también
mil por mil tenemos tres ceros y tres
ceros tenemos seis ceros mil por mil es
igual a un millón dieciséis por un
millón es igual a 16 millones espero que
esto ayude a multiplicar números como
estos que son múltiplos de 10 100.000 e
incluso millones